they're gonna legalize prop and
partially to solve this problem I don't
know I just I think of these ideas if
they're armies of men going their own
way living debt free that's the last
thing that the Elites in our society
want instead they're interested in
keeping the cash flowing to the poor so
that they will continue to vote for
their left-leaning politicians so the
people can oh that's so interesting
facts
wow wow because if the women are single
then we spend more wow I will disagree I
do think men lie for sex yeah men like
to get sex but that's about it yeah what
up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell the way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way and
guys let's get to 2 000 likes on this
video that's the most important metric
that YouTube uses to push out these
streams welcome to the channel Christine
a special guest as usual hello again
Christine is our newest Talent at the
audacity Network guys make sure you go
subscribe to our Network page that will
be in the description below and make
sure you subscribe to Christine's
Channel as well we're trying to get her
monetized this week into a thousand
subscribers I'm out of town
um this week so they're probably going
to be posting these so make sure you
tune in to Christine's essay videos
where she debunks the debauchery of
today yeah or at least try to make some
kind of sense of it you can only do so
much yeah anyways
um guys guys
um today we are gonna be reacting to
another mgtow video marrying poor woman
women you know I spoke to my trainer the
other day and he told me that when he
was younger they used to go to job
centers to pick up women because they
knew all the women were unemployed there
one of his friends like found a wife
there I can't really argue with the
logic behind that makes a lot of sense
they're like she's got a lot of free
time yeah she's gonna be at home she
needs someone to support her
so uh we'll see I wonder if the mgtow
guys I don't think they're gonna be for
marrying poor women because of the
system that's my guess I don't think
that's what they're gonna tell the men
to do but let's see I could be wrong hi
everyone same man here this video is
brought to you by a donation from Jim in
Vancouver and here's what he has to say
hi Sandman men have been raised since
birth to Mary for love it doesn't matter
if a woman is poor my parents would
often say men do this and they end up
taking a dependent even when there are
no kids in the mix men still end up
subsidizing a woman in their lives boys
tend to be self-starters very few boys I
know needed financial help from their
parents they find summer jobs go to
school and start careers largely on
their own girls on the other hand don't
generally have the same work ethic to
begin with they expect their parents to
buy them a car a cell phone which also
means paying the phone bill they need
all their school expenses paid as well
I've spoken to many parents who are
frustrated because their daughter
refuses to get a summer job to help pay
for schooling instead she wants to
travel Europe with her friends and of
course she'll need that paid for too
many women remain dependents upon their
parents until they find a man to support
them and often even afterwards they just
keep on taking women choose careers that
do not require them to work Outdoors or
do any kind of hazardous work women
prefer air conditioning flexible hours
and they generally are against working
away from home such as in a Work Camp
back in the 1970s equal pay for equal
work was the buzz phrase once that was
attained and rightly so it then morphed
into equal pay for work of equal value
who would be you know it's funny it's
like we do less work and we get more
money per hour you know what I mean like
when you think about it what's more
valuable than running society yet under
30 were out earning men is that is that
right under 30 in major cities yeah it's
not everywhere but in major cities we
are out earning men I think it's though
because we monetize Beauty yeah that's
my guess yeah yeah but it's like these
women they're just whiners that's like
my thing I'm just tired of the whining
go be in a man's world I don't care like
I don't really care what you do but it's
just like I don't want you to whine it's
a shame that that 70s slogan was lost
equal pay for equal work no because it's
never equal like even though WNBA
um it's like equal they just want free
money yeah and women aren't willing to
go and do the jobs that men do no I mean
I don't want to I'm good I'll take less
money for not doing that that's fine
don't put me in that the Arbiter in
charge of comparing a man's job to a
woman's job in order to assess so-called
pay Equity so why not do this between
men's jobs as well we should all get
paid the same a bunch of socialists bunk
women hardly ever marry a man who makes
less than they do almost never a female
doctor doesn't marry a plumber she
marries a specialist why because since
birth women have been told they should
find a rich man to marry someone who can
buy them all the things that they would
ever want and if they get divorced this
thing called alimony kicks in we're
whereas the man has to keep her in the
lifestyle that she's accustomed to yet
Society is also brainwashed to believe
that women are somehow morally Superior
to men when the opposite is actually
true men marry for love not money men
are honest about their intentions and
drives for women it is a game of lying
and coercion could you please expound on
some of these points for us I love your
show you are providing essential insight
to men everywhere we need to stick
together and support one another Well
Jim I will disagree I do think men lie
for sex yeah men lie to get sex but
that's about it yeah for donation and
comments and I'm sure I'm going to talk
about a few different topics from what
you had to say first of all it's not
just young women that are dependent on
their parents I knew one woman and she
was pretty much grown up and yet her dad
was paying half of her rent all the time
while she was living with her husband he
was also paying the other half she was
living for free and saving the money and
basically put it in the bank and used it
for vacations to places like Greece
turkey Japan and the United States she
wasn't putting anything away for
retirement but instead spending all the
free money that men gave her in her life
I'm talking about a grown woman in her
30s and 40s telling others how to Live
While living on other people's money so
in a way her parents paid for her trips
when she was younger and ended up paying
for her trips when she was a lot older I
put a link in the description to a video
called dried up feminists or poor guess
who they blame they're finding in
Australia that women over the age of 55
have half as much money save for
retirement that men do this demographic
of women wow I'm not not surprised but
I'm gonna use that stat wow half as much
money by 55 and yet they'll say we
should be in charge of the household
money I think it makes perfect sense
that we shouldn't be I don't want to add
yeah I hate my me too I'm like I hate
adding I like to English
give me away it was also becoming the
fastest growing part of the homeless
population women are now complaining
that men have more money in retirement
it's obviously unfair and we need
equality I remember reading last year if
we're throwing more of it away I don't
like math but that's some pretty basic
math to me you know it's funny man we're
like a net loss for taxpayers like we
spend more money yeah than we make
yeah like we take more money from the
government than we make we're a net loss
yeah it's like almost like this they
subsidize us to like live and it's funny
like women it's so hard to talk to women
about this because we they always go to
like personal well I don't do that it's
like I've never been on a benefit in my
life but it's like truth is a lot like I
could see what it is yeah like I'm not
blind that wealthier men in Western
societies were actually outliving poor
lower middle-income women women couldn't
deal with this fact either also Jim
thanks for bringing up to my attention
this equal pay for equal work slogan
being changed to equal pay for work of
equal value I had no idea that was done
the question to ask is who determines
what has more value the guy's just
thinking that like who determines what's
valuable
probably women yeah possibly I think the
new slogan you mentioned is all about
tricking men into longer and harder work
hours meanwhile women get the same
amount of pay for doing less that's how
Communism works you get paid based on
position instead of performance we all
know that social justice Warriors want
to devalue male work and pay women more
money even if they do less there's
nothing new about this of course our
gynocentric culture still promotes the
idea that men should pretty much man up
and support women it's in the male DNA
to do that also of course women don't
marry a man that makes less money than
they do that goes against the laws of
hypergamy it's also not just about money
when it comes to women in mate selection
I know wealthy plumbers and electricians
and even female doctors that make less
money than they do and they still won't
date those guys let alone marry them
they are looked down upon when it comes
to status because God forbid they go out
with their wealthy successful friends
and have to introduce their low-class
husband Pete the Plumber to their
friends you know what's funny if the
Lights Went Out Tomorrow the plumber
could probably protect you and like help
you more than the banker yep which is
high status you know what I mean like if
you think of a traditional husband I I
would imagine the plumber the
electrician would have more skills yeah
rather than we've changed status haven't
we we've changed status from actual like
but if you go back way back I don't have
a time period but yeah if you go way
back it's like the man who was most
desirable was the man who in all types
of Crisis knew what to do now we're like
oh status is basically the man in the
suit with the highest paid job rather
than the man no I actually I don't know
if that's I think I don't think it's new
because I think when I think of like a
king or the like whatever the governors
it's not like they were doing the
carpentry and sure yeah they just ruled
over the yeah you know because I think
like the merchant versus the king yeah
like I doubt I don't know I'm just
thinking though I'd have to I'd have to
there's um a guy that wrote the history
of sex that talked about all these
intersexual Dynamics throughout history
it'd be interesting I might ask him
because you ask a man yeah
while all the rest of them have
successful doctor and Banker husbands to
boot just imagine the scandals to be
spoken of while everyone eats their
cream chicken men are told to man up and
marry poor women and support them and
improve their lives but you never hear
anything about a woman doing the same
thing for a man things have always
pretty much been like this except in the
past the woman couldn't divorce you and
take your kids and your stuff back then
women had duties and responsibilities
and they couldn't weasel their way out
of them with regards to the husband and
children today their responsibilities
are to themselves and they aren't having
as many kids and they are getting
married also wealthy guys in their 50s
and 60s don't want to marry poor women
over the age of 55. Imagine what's going
to happen as more men go their own way
and automation starts taking away the
jobs of 55 year old plus cat ladies the
cat food will be harder to come by oh my
gosh I heard that's what AI is going to
do it's gonna take away women's jobs
pretty much not like all the marketing
managers AI is that a bad thing like
really like because you saying about how
we basically subsidize women so it's
like if if they're still gonna pay
the women to not work I wonder if
they'll just find a new job we don't
need like HR
that's what I think because I literally
this girl I knew out of college she made
really good money out of college and she
went into HR like she made like 55k a
year which back this was like five years
ago too so the currency wasn't so
inflated because 55k there is like I
don't know 45 35 here yeah but like back
then still quite a good income it was a
good income and I remember thinking like
I need to go into this HR business yes
like yeah HRS I don't know it seems what
do you really do it's just like making
contracts to control men
I was like what is that and the cats
might eat her while she's sleeping just
imagine what happens when half the women
over 55 are unemployed some are homeless
and they're now looking for a man to
basically blame I've said before that
the government might actually Force some
sort of redistribution of wealth scheme
from the privilege to the unprivileged
males and more specifically white and
Asian males being the most financially
privileged so therefore we might have to
chip in to keep our troubled sisters
from hitting the streets remember if
women are single in their 50s and 60s
with no money and their parents are dead
it's going to be the responsibility of
the state to take care of them and the
state clearly doesn't want to be the
case isn't it kind of already the case
that the people who are
making the money and working hard and
doing the 90 hours a week or paying for
the people a lot of the people who
aren't doing that and that's not to say
that there aren't exceptions and there
are people who can't work for whatever
reason and I'm not saying you know
whether those people deserve help or not
but it is a fact that the majority of
people who are claiming benefits and
things like that
um they could work I I actually knew
someone and I was working as an estate
agent and there was a guy who left
working as an estate agent because he
realized he could make just as much
money off of the benefit system being at
home with his three kids as he could
being at work so it's like if we're
going to reward people for doing nothing
then they're gonna do nothing then
they're gonna do nothing and it is
already a fact that the people who are
working the 90-hour weeks and you know
making the majority of money get taxed
the highest so they are basically
already paying for the people I know at
the bottom I know so many people I mean
maybe it's just because of the industry
I'm in but I know so many people that
have moved to Dubai because of the tax
yeah because they're taxed because
they're just sick of paying for other
people yeah and then you start to lose
like the best and the brightest because
they're just sick of this [__] yeah
tired of working just to give it to you
know men who don't want to work yeah
people that don't want to work if the
state doesn't find a way to solve this
problem then those women will use their
I think they're going to legalize
prostitution partially to solve this
problem I heard recently that there
aren't they like shutting it down in
Amsterdam in the red light no way I I
don't know if this is true I heard of
something that would be great that's
like what they're known for right
wow I'm curious because last year I
heard New York was going to make
prostitution legal so I wondered if in
the U.S they were going to start to make
it legal to deal with some of these
older women was it ever legal like was
it legal say like 100 years ago I don't
know actually I know in Vegas like
escorting's legal so it's basically the
same thing yeah it's like yeah there are
certain cities I I think it should be
illegal now I know I know a lot of
people I decided this yesterday I've
been going back and forth but I decided
this yesterday because I decided I
wanted I know people are gonna do it
anyway but I don't want to live in a
world where you can go down the street
and do it
agreed I don't want to see stores like I
want I the cops can look the other way
yeah but people do things differently
when it's like when it's legal and yeah
yeah like I don't like how you can walk
down the street and buy weed weed used
to be taboo yeah like it used to be like
if you oh my God you caught your kid
doing weed now it's like normal yeah
everyone it's you just go down and buy
it yeah yeah yeah it wasn't when I was
growing up it was not like that so I'm
like do I want the same thing to happen
with hookers where a 20 year old guy can
just go down the street and get one
or worse a 16 year old guy yeah yeah
like I mean I think that would
definitely happen with the level of
sexless like men where it's so easy down
like it can happen but I think they need
to put in a little work to commit the
crime yeah we could look the other way I
don't care if the cops police it that
hard but it needs to be on the books
illegally in my opinion I decided this
yes what kind of a world is that where
it's like oh we the the society has
deemed it
okay
I don't know yeah it's the same reason I
think like it's kind of the way I look
at only fans as well though because I'm
like what kind of world do we live in
now where it's like we see that as
empowering like that I think that like
that hurts me as a female so I'm like
why is that something that my daughters
are gonna have to see as some kind of
virtue well and I was thinking if they
made only fans illegal because I've
thought about this too the influencers
couldn't do it so openly you know what I
mean like we're your favorite influencer
starts and only fans makes millions of
dollars if they did that they would have
the inconvenience of having to move
somewhere else
so probably less people would do it yes
you kind of fix the problem as a whole
correct you can do it that's fine you
can make your secret only fans but I
reserve the right to prosecute you and I
think we should Pro I mean I'm not
saying use all of our police resources
to take them down but like the big like
the bad Barbies the big influencers yeah
you should go get them if they keep
doing it after in Pearl's world we ban
it
finding privileged voting rights to vote
in political parties that will give them
a better lifestyle if they elect
governments to take for men to give to
women more men will stop producing or if
they do earn more money they'll convert
it to Gold cash or Bitcoin to avoid
taxes here in Canada the government is
now looking at creating some sort of tax
for gender right now they're planning on
this system at the moment isn't it that
looks like a calm you know the more I
hear about it I'm like I gotta stay out
of there remind me never to go to Canada
creations and taxing them more heavily
the majority of such businesses are
currently held by men so I'm guessing
that men with small corporations will
have to pay more tax they're already
going after so-called privileged male
doctors and entrepreneurs here the thing
to remember is that the world is
changing this idea of women being
dependent on men might have been the
case while you were growing up in while
I was growing up Jim but single-person
households are making up the bulk of
households here in Toronto as I'm sure
they are in Vancouver where you are as
well men spend less money and they save
more of it the key to everything is to
get those men married and divorced so
that their spending power can be
unlocked in order to create new debt and
transfer the cash to women if they're
armies of men going their own way living
debt free that's the last thing that the
Elites in our society want instead
they're interested in keeping the cash
flowing to the poor so that they will
continue to vote for their left-leaning
politicians so that people can oh that's
so interesting facts
wow wow because if the women are single
then we spend more wow be further
impoverished many men today are likely
to own multiple properties and rent
those out to women just look over
invention mgtail and what he was doing
he bought an apartment and rented it out
to a feminist while he enjoyed his mgtow
lifestyle and I believe he sold that
apartment just over a year ago he has
assets and was making money off of them
and the feminist woman didn't actually
have anything so as more men go their
own way and automation expands many
women in their 40s 50s and Beyond with
little to no assets will be unemployable
and no one will want them except perhaps
beta male simps but after a certain age
even the simps won't want them anymore
either that or many of the simps will be
in their 60s and 70s are dead the second
article I put in the descriptions from
Australia and it says that Rising
divorce rates are to blame for women
being homeless and poor but considering
that seventy percent of all wait forces
are initiated by women they have only
themselves to blame for that particular
situation unfortunately I know that's
why when they're like oh women fare
worse after divorce I'm like
all right
one men commit more suicide after
divorce so let's talk about that fact
and two then blame your damn self stay
with your your kid's father like I'm not
I'm not even you know honestly I don't
even really have that much like like if
a girl wants to divorce her husband
doesn't do the alimony doesn't do any of
that [__] and just wants to be by
herself is willing to pay for herself
for a lifetime go do it go but the
majority of women can't do it that's why
it's irritating it's like you literally
can't do it so stop whining and
complaining and blaming the men and just
get along with your husband and then
they'll think I'm crazy by saying yes
you should just stay together and figure
out how to get along
yeah because people don't really want to
get along with anyone anymore we live in
a world where it's like oh everything's
got to be me me me me and you know I
hate everyone else and I'm good by
myself and it's like what a lonely life
we just love the Kardashians where they
get a new man every like year it's gonna
be interesting I wonder who Kim
Kardashian's next Pub I see I like it
I'm like who's her next public boyfriend
I wish you're gonna come after Pete
Davidson you know what I mean yeah where
do you go after that how crazy is it he
was like a drug addict too at one point
so she's literally bringing a drug
addict in the house and they're like
praising it what a great mom she's out
like partying they're like wow Queen
like these four kids are like where are
they where are they like give the kids
to yay then if this is the life you want
to live yeah yeah yeah yeah get your kid
on Tick Tock dancing with ice spice like
this is wild this is madness women are
incapable of taking blame for their own
actions according to that article It
also says the Charities are reporting a
44 increase in the number of older women
seeking homelessness services in the
last five years they also say that the
death of the partner is another reason
for the suffering of these women the
problem is that women on average are a
lot worse when it comes to delayed
gratification and saving money for their
retirement so just as many Western State
Pension funds start to run dry and
marriage rates start falling and robots
start taking away jobs that's when women
become independent and empower Howard
they couldn't have picked the worst time
to choose this men are expected to help
women in sacrifice but now men in the
west are beginning to become herbivores
or mgtows and choosing not to support
women but instead are now focusing on
themselves all this reminds me of the
story of the boy that cried wolf he lied
about being attacked by the wolf so many
times the people stopped listening to
him and eventually when the wolf comes
for the women they will be ignored and
the women will get swallowed up the
perfect analogy for what has happened
with feminism
like it is literally the boy who cried
wolf where we're screaming you know men
are doing this when they're doing that
again not to say that there are
exceptions but majority of it is a lot
of
victim mentality and making men this
great oppressive thing and we're just
the little victims it's like you keep
doing that you're gonna become that do
you ever hear the word misogynist or
sexist and take it seriously no do you
even really take the word seriously
anymore not anymore no if I see
the word I automatically look for
afterwards is allegation or accusation
yeah and it's sad because there's real
victims that real victims are the people
actually getting hurt by this it's the
people who are actually victims of
things like you know sexual assault that
they're the ones suffering for it we
aren't hurting anyone other than
ourselves like I get that obviously you
know we're destroying men's lives in the
process but it's the actual women who
are the victims that are at the biggest
loss because they're just gonna come out
or at least try and come out and say
this is what happened and people are
going to go well you're just trying to
destroy this guy's life or Worse they're
gonna see what's going on and that
people are kind of waking up to all of
these allegations
um and they won't say anything
yeah it's so it's the same system boohoo
you're a victim and you can be the hero
if you overcome this victimhood of men
it's like
whatever is that if women lie all the
time eventually men won't believe them
even when they're telling the truth
according to the third link in the
description to an interpretation of that
story from Star Trek Deep Space Nine if
women complain about being oppressed and
Men figure out that it's all a lie then
when these women are in their 50s and
60s and Beyond and are truly in poverty
men simply won't care to listen anymore
of course in Star Trek Deep Space Nine
the character Garrick says that the real
point of the story is that you should
never tell the same lie twice which is
probably why women lie about almost
everything that way if you catch them
telling One Lie then the odds are pretty
good you won't catch them at any others
but something tells me that this time
women aren't lying if they're old
without any children or husband or
pension and in Australia the rents and
housing prices are astronomical it's
quite true that women could find
themselves homeless and poor in the not
so distant future even those
50-something women that want a job as a
Walmart greeter will pretty much not
have that option as stores get rid of
registers and security entirely and all
transactions are made with RFID check
tips when women are young and their
parents Supply them with a car and phone
and the parents are helping them out
they're actually hurting them the girls
don't learn how to Value money and
therefore when they go out and look for
men to date and possibly marry they
won't be able to Value those men either
women are terrible judges of value and
that's probably why they buy thousand
dollar purses and 500 pairs of shoes
some people even say that men have
issues with spending but if that were
really the case why are there 80 to 90
percent of the stores and malls selling
women only Goods you're right Jim it's
socialism and you live in Vancouver one
of the most socialist cities in one of
the most socialist provinces in Canada
one of the most socialist countries in
the world let's just pray they don't
introduce a BC bachelor's tax to help
the women's in your Province you know
what I was thinking what if they paid
women to be to stop being fat like
instead of paying women to be single
mothers we get the same benefits but for
getting married not being fat and and
um giving them like three plus children
because that's the replacement rate but
you know what I mean like they're
already like subsidizing the women
anyway like what are they wouldn't be
able to play victims and then they'd
actually be being praised for doing
something good for themselves in society
yeah and I just think that's a bit too
complex and too much to grasp rather
than yeah I'm a victim it's the men yeah
well they can't control us as much but I
was thinking they take the men's money
and give it to us anyway I'm like what
if they just made it the opposite like
things that we like would be good yeah
like maybe there's some
this is probably too far but imagine
okay they you could go to the
gynecologist to prove your virginity on
your wedding day right right and there
was some sort of like like prize you
know what's funny I bet more women would
do it for money than their husbands 100
that's the funny part that's the funny
part but you know it's like ten thousand
dollars five thousand whatever like a
lifetime of child support would cost you
just put that for virginity on the
wedding
I don't know I just I think of these
ideas
um well what do you think your second
mgtow video again like I I can
understand why this is happening I I
think it's completely fair enough and it
makes sense and you know everything he
said is happening in the world so I
can't really argue with men going their
own way because if I was a man and this
was all happening to me
I'd be thinking yeah if you get all of
this I'm out I'm good they're gonna
start taking power back I think at some
point I think there's going to be a
collapse and they'll take that's my
guess but I don't know I I heard they
did that in ancient Greece like or
something when the women started to get
too wild like I guess that's how you can
tell a society's about to collapse and
the women are bad and you can't tell the
difference between hookers and wives I
was like that is definitely what's
happening now just on social media yeah
these girls will be like wives and
mothers and I'm like what's up here if
someone said something I think it was on
like a Joe Rogan podcast someone said
about how ripe for societies collapse
gender becomes the main topic of
conversation no way yeah wait oh we need
to find this video because I I saw it
was a really short clip maybe it was
taken out of context but they definitely
said that right before society's
collapsed the women start becoming the
main voice in society like all the
narratives are run by women and that
gender becomes the main topic of
conversation
wow yeah send that to me that'd be a
good video but guys let me know what you
think in the comments
um Can women be safe like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
we'll talk to you oh and make sure you
subscribe to Christine's Channel get her
to a thousand subscribers like the video
on your way out we'll talk to you next
time